Mishawaka tiene muchas cosas buenas pero no es el centro cultural del mundo
por lo que mi únicos encuentros con el teatro y el cine se limitaron
a las obras que estudié en la secundaria
y vi en Blockbuster Video, que en paz descanse. (Risas)
Era lo suficientemente bueno
para obtener una audición para Juilliard en el último año de secundaria;
no entré pero decidí que la universidad no era para mí así que no me presenté
en ninguna otra parte, lo que demuestra lo listo que era.
También intenté la odisea sobre la que se cuenta un sinfín de historias,
la de los actores que llegan a Los Ángeles con USD 7
buscan trabajo y tienen una carrera exitosa.
Yo llegué hasta Amarillo, Texas, antes de que el coche se averiara.
Gasté todo mi dinero en reparaciones
para acabar en Santa Mónica, ni siquiera Los Ángeles,
donde me quedé 48 horas paseándome por la playa, básicamente,
recuperé mi coche y volví a casa poniendo así fin a mi carrera de actor.
(Risas)
Así que estoy en Mishawaka con 17 años
en la casa de mis padres, pago alquiler, vendo aspiradoras,
hago tele-marketing,
corto el césped en los parques de atracciones 4-H locales.
Este era mi mundo en septiembre de 2001.
Así que después del 11-S, abrumado por una sensación de deber
mientras estaba enojado en general conmigo mismo,
con mis padres y el gobierno,
sin confianza, o un trabajo respetable
y con solo un minirefrigerador de mierda que arrastré a California y de vuelta,
me uní a la Infantería de Marina y me encantó.
Es una de las cosas que más me enorgullece haber hecho en mi vida.
Era genial disparar armas, conducir y detonar cosas,
pero descubrí que amaba el cuerpo de marina por algo
que no estaba buscando en absoluto, por lo menos no cuando me alisté,
y que era la gente: estos tipos raros, gente de lo más variopinta
de una zona de los Estados Unidos
con la que aparentemente no tenía nada en común.
Y con el tiempo, toda la bravuconería política y personal
que me atrajo al ejército se disipó
y el Cuerpo de Marines se convirtió para mí en sinónimo de mis amigos.
Al cabo de unos años de servicio y meses antes de ser enviado a Irak,
me disloqué el esternón en un accidente de bicicleta de montaña,
y me quedé por razones médicas.
Para los que nunca han estado en el ejército, resulta difícil de entender
pero recibir la noticia de que no iba a ir a Irak o Afganistán me devastó.
Recuerdo claramente dejar el hospital de la base en una camilla
con todo mi pelotón fuera, a la espera para ver si estaba bien.
Y entonces, de repente, volví a ser de nuevo un civil.
Supe que quería darle otra oportunidad a la actuación,
porque, una vez más -- este soy yo -- pensé
que todos los problemas civiles son pequeños comparados con los militares.
Es decir, ¿de qué puede uno realmente quejarse ahora?
"Hace calor. Alguien debe poner el aire".
"La fila para comprarse un café es demasiado larga".
Yo era un marine, sabía sobrevivir.
Me gustaría ir a Nueva York y convertirme en actor.
Y si las cosas no salían bien, iba a vivir en Central Park
y vivir del contenedor de basura de Panera Bread. (Risas)
Me presente a otra audición para Juilliard y esta vez tuve suerte, entré.
Pero me sorprendió lo complejo que era la transición de militar a civil.
Yo estaba bastante sano y no puedo imaginarme pasar por ese proceso
con un daño mental o físico.
Pero independientemente de todo esto, era difícil.
En parte, porque estudiaba actuación
y no podía pasar por alto que yo iba a clases de voz y de oratoria,
lanzaba pelotas imaginarias de energía hasta al fondo del aula
y hacía ejercicios donde me daba a luz a mí mismo
(Risas)
mientras mis amigos estaban sirviendo sin mí en el extranjero.
Pero también, porque no sabía cómo aplicar las cosas
que aprendí en el ejército en un contexto civil.
Quiero decir tanto en la práctica como emocionalmente.
En la práctica, necesitaba trabajo y yo era un marine,
acostumbrado a disparar ametralladoras y morteros.
No hay muchos lugares en el mundo civil donde se busquen esas habilidades.
(Risas)
Y, emocionalmente, me costó encontrar sentido en la vida.
En el ejército, todo tiene sentido.
Lo que hacemos sigue una gran tradición o bien tiene un propósito práctico.
No se puede fumar al aire libre para no delatar la ubicación.
No se toca la cara porque hay que mantener un nivel personal de salud y de higiene.
Miras hacia aquí cuando suena el himno por respeto a los que lucharon antes.
Camina así, habla de esta manera por esto y aquello.
El uniforme se lleva con pulcritud,
la manera de seguir esas reglas dicen mucho de ti,
del tipo de marine que eres.
El rango indica tu pasado y el respeto que te has ganado.
En el mundo civil no hay rango.
Aquí eres un cuerpo más,
y me sentí como si tuviera que demostrar constantemente mi valía una y otra vez.
Y el respeto que recibí de los civiles mientras estaba de uniforme
desapareció cuando iba de civil.
No parecía que me rodeaba un sentido de comunidad,
mientras que en el ejército, me sentí muy arropado.
¿Cuán a menudo se encuentran en el mundo civil en una situación de vida o muerte
donde los amigos más cercanos
les demuestran constantemente que no les abandonarán?
Mientras tanto, en la escuela de actuación
(Risas)
descubrí por primera vez autores y personajes y obras
que no tenían nada que ver con los militares,
pero que de alguna manera describían mi experiencia militar
de un modo inconcebible para mí hasta entonces.
Y cada vez me sentía menos agresivo,
ya que podía expresar con palabras mi sentimientos por primera vez
y me di cuenta de que era una herramienta muy valiosa.
Y al pensar en mi servicio militar
dejé de notar los típicos ejercicios disciplinarios y el dolor que producían
y más bien recordaba estos pequeños momentos humanos íntimos,
repletos de sentimientos, con amigos
ausentándose sin permiso por echar de menos a sus familias,
amigos que iban a divorciarse, que lloraban o celebraban juntos,
mientras éramos militares.
Los vi luchar con estas circunstancias y vi la ansiedad en ellos y en mí
dejándonos incapaces de expresar nuestros sentimientos al respecto.
En realidad, la comunidad militar y la teatral son muy similares.
Hablamos de un grupo de personas que intentan llevar a cabo una misión
más grande que ellos donde no se trata de ti,
sino que tienes un papel, y hay que saber cuál es dentro de ese equipo
que tiene un líder o un director a veces inteligente, a veces no.
Uno está obligado a intimar con extraños en un corto período de tiempo;
autodisciplinarse y ser autosuficiente.
Y pensé qué sería fantástico crear un espacio que pudiese reunir
estas dos comunidades aparentemente disímiles
para entretener a un grupo de personas que, teniendo en cuenta su ocupación,
les vendría bien un poco más de reflexión
en lugar de la típica diversión obligatoria
de la cual recuerdo disfrutar voluntariamente en el ejército.
(Risas)
Eventos todos bien intencionados pero ligeramente ofensivos
como "Gana una cita con una animadora de los San Diego Chargers",
donde si contestas correctamente a una pregunta de la cultura pop,
ganas la cita, que es un paseo acompañado durante el desfile
con esta animadora casada y embarazada.
(Risas)
No tengo nada en contra de ellas, me encantan,
pero no sería genial introducir el teatro
mediante personajes accesibles sin ser condescendiente.
Así que abrimos "Artes en las Fuerzas Armadas", una empresa sin ánimo de lucro
donde intentamos hacer eso, unir a estas dos comunidades aparentemente opuestas.
Elegimos una obra o seleccionamos monólogos
de teatro estadounidense contemporáneo
igual de diversos en edad y raza como lo es una audiencia militar.
Contamos con un grupo de actores de teatro increíbles,
les damos material increíble
mientras mantenemos el valor de la producción al mínimo:
sin decorados, vestuario, iluminación, solo lecturas,
todo para poner en evidencia el lenguaje
y demostrar que se puede hacer teatro en cualquier entorno.
Es algo muy poderoso,
esto de encontrarse en una habitación rodeado por completos extraños
para recordarnos a nosotros mismos nuestra humanidad,
y ver que este poder de expresión
es una herramienta igual de valiosa que un rifle al hombro.
Y para una organización como la militar que se enorgullece de hablar poco
uno puede sentirse perdido al tratar de explicar una experiencia colectiva.
Y no hay mejor comunidad que necesite una nueva manera de expresarse
que la que protege nuestro país.
Hemos estado de gira por todos Estados Unidos y el mundo,
de Walter Reed en Bethesda, Maryland,
a Camp Pendleton, o Camp Arifjan en Kuwait,
a USAG Baviera y teatros en Broadway o por toda Nueva York,
Y a los artistas que traemos les brindamos una ventana hacia una cultura
que de otra manera no llegarían a conocer.
Y para los militares es exactamente lo mismo.
Y el hacer esto durante los últimos seis años,
siempre me obliga recordar que la actuación es muchas cosas.
Es un arte, un acto político, un negocio,
lo que más consideren oportuno en su caso,
pero también es un servicio.
Yo no llegué a terminar el mío,
así que siempre que tengo la oportunidad de servir
a esta definitiva industria de servicios, los militares, para mí, una vez más,
no hay mayor honor.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Interpretaremos un fragmento de la obra de Marco Ramírez,
llamada "No soy Batman".
Jesse Pérez un actor increíble y buen amigo mío, nos va a leer
y estará acompañado por Matt Johnson que acabo de conocer hace un par de horas,
por primera vez, así que ya veremos cómo sale.
Jesse Pérez y Matt Johnson.
(Aplausos)
Jesse Pérez: Es medianoche
y el cielo rojo radiactivo, que ilumina como loco.
Y si observas, quizá puedas ver la luna
a través de una espesa capa de humo de cigarrillo y de gases de escape de avión
que cubre la ciudad como un mosquitero que no deja pasar ni a los ángeles.
Y si miras lo suficientemente alto,
me verás a mí, parado en el borde de un edificio de 87 pisos.
Y allí arriba, en este lugar para gárgolas y relojes rotos en las torres,
que permanecen inmóviles desde hace quizás 100 años,
allí estoy yo.
(Toque de tambor)
Y soy el maldito Batman.
Y tengo batimóviles y batibúmerangs
y malditas cuevas llenas de murciélagos, en serio.
Y todo lo que necesito es un armario de la limpieza
o un cuarto trasero o una escalera de incendios,
para hacer desaparecer a mis vaqueros de segunda mano.
Y mi polo azul marino, que me queda bien
pero tiene ese agujero desde cuando me enganché
en la valla de tela metálica detrás de "Arturo's"
aunque no es gran cosa
porque me lo meto en los pantalones y todo queda bien.
Aquel polo azul, ¡adiós, también!
Y me me vuelvo..., me... ¡me transformo!
(Toque de tambor)
Y nadie saca el cinturón para zurrar a Batman por responder.
O por no responder.
Y nadie llama a Batman simplón o estúpido o delgaducho.
Y nadie despide al hermano de Batman de la Eastern Taxi Company
porque están haciendo recortes tampoco.
Porque todos lo respetan.
Y no como el respeto que viene del miedo
sino más bien, respeto-respeto.
(Risas)
Porque nadie te tiene miedo.
Porque Batman no quiere hacer daño a nadie.
(Toque de tambor)
Nunca. (Golpe doble)
Porque todo lo que quiere Batman es salvar a la gente
y tal vez pagar las facturas de su abuela y un día morir feliz.
Y quizás volverse famoso de verdad.
(Risas)
Ah, y matar al Acertijo.
(Redoble de tambor)
Esta noche, al igual que casi todas, estoy solo.
Y vigilo y espero como un águila, o como un...
No, mejor como un águila.
(Risas)
Y mi capa ondea en el viento porque es jodidamente larga
y mis orejas puntiagudas están levantadas
y la máscara que cubre la mitad de mi cara también la tengo puesta.
Y mi ropa es a prueba de balas para que nadie pueda hacerme daño.
Y nadie, ¡nadie!, se interpondrá entre Batman y la justicia.
(Batería) (Risas)
Desde donde estoy puedo oírlo todo.
(Silencio)
En alguna parte hay una anciana
recogiendo sobras de espuma de poliestireno de un bote de basura
mientras se come un trozo de pollo con sésamo que alguien escupió.
Y en algún lugar hay un médico con un corte de pelo raro
con una bata de laboratorio negra tratando de encontrar una cura
para una enfermedad que un día acabará con todos nosotros.
Y en algún lugar hay un hombre en uniforme de portero,
de camino a casa, borracho y mareado,
que gastó la mitad de su paga en botellas de cerveza de un litro,
y la otra mitad en una visita de 4 horas a la casa de una señora que vive
donde cierta gente disparó a las luces de la calle
ya que prefieren hacer lo que hacen en esta ciudad en la oscuridad.
Y muy cerca del conserje, hay un grupo de buenos-para-nada
que no saben hacer nada mejor que esperarle armados
con cadenas de bicicleta oxidadas y unos bates de imitación.
Y si ven que no tiene dinero, -- que no tendrá --
le pegarán hasta que se les cansen los músculos de los brazos
y hasta que no queden más dientes por romper.
Pero ellos no cuentan conmigo.
No cuentan con ningún caballero de la noche,
con el estómago lleno de macarrones, queso de marca y salchichas vienesas.
(Risas)
Prefiero que crean que no existo.
Y desde donde estoy, a 87 pisos de altura, oigo a uno de ellos decir así de rápido:
"¡Dame el dinero!"¡, "¡Dame el puto dinero!"
Y veo al conserje murmurar algo en el lenguaje borracho y palidecer.
Y desde los 87 pisos de altura,
siento cómo el miedo le invade y busca una vía de escape.
Así que me abalanzo rápidamente
en la oscuridad, vuelo en picada
y lanzo un batibúmerang a una de las bombillas.
(Platillos)
Y les oigo decir: "¡Caramba! ¿Quién ha apagado las luces?"
(Risas)
"¿Qué es eso de ahí?" "¿Qué?"
"¡Dame todo lo que tienes, viejo!"
"¿Has oído esto?"
"¿Oír qué? Si no hay nada. ¡No, en serio, no hay ningún murciélago!"
Y entonces,
uno de los tres holgazanes recibe un golpe: ¡pam!
Mientras que el segundo lucha a ciegas contra mi capa oscura
y antes de que su puño golpee algo
le tiro la tapa de un contendedor de basura en pleno estómago.
Y el tercero intenta patearme de un salto pero yo también sé karate y judo,
así que le golpeo así.
(Batería)
¡Dos veces!
(Risas)
(Batería)
Y antes de que pueda hacer más daño,
todos oímos de repente un "clic-clic".
Y de repente todo se vuelve tranquilo.
Y el último holgazán que queda en pie
agarra una pistola y apunta directamente hacia arriba,
como si fuera que tiene a Jesús de rehén y está listo para agujerear la luna,
mientras que el primero a quién golpeé en la cabeza
y trató de patearme,
junto con el otro,
tratan de retirarse y alejarse de la silueta oscura que tienen delante.
Y el borracho, el conserje, está acurrucado en un rincón
y reza a San Antonio ya que es el único a quién recuerda.
(Golpe doble)
Y allí estoy yo:
con los ojos brillando en la oscuridad
y la capa ondeando suavemente en el aire
(Batería)
con el pecho palpitando
y el corazón latiendo en código Morse, que dice:
"Métete conmigo solo una vez.
Vamos, inténtalo".
Y el bueno-para-nada que queda en pie,
con el arma en la mano, me mira y se ríe.
Y baja el brazo con el arma apuntándome a mí ahora
en vez de a la luna.
Y apunta justo entre mis orejas puntiagudas
que sirven de postes de portería
como si fuera que es de los equipos especiales.
El conserje sigue rezando a San Antonio, pero no se levanta.
Y por un segundo, parece
que tal vez, voy a perder.
¡Qué va!
(Batería)
¡Bang! ¡Bang! Disparos. "¡No me mates, hombre!"
¡Pam! ¡Llave de muñeca! ¡Golpe a la garganta!
Le arrojo ácido a la cara mientras grita.
Está en el suelo y yo encima de él, sujetando su arma
y no me gustan las pistolas, no me gustan las armas porque soy Batman.
Y, paréntesis: A Batman no le gusta las armas
porque así murieron sus padres hace mucho tiempo.
Pero solo por un segundo me brillan los ojos, porque tengo esta cosa
con la que puedo hablar con el holgazán en un idioma que quizás entienda mejor.
¡Clic-clic!
(Golpe de batería)
Y el holgazán se esfuma como un residuo tóxico
de vuelta a la pocilga llena de lodo de donde salió.
Y quedo solo yo con el portero.
Y lo levanto, le quito el sudor y el perfume barato de la frente.
Y él me implora que no le haga daño
mientras le agarro por el cuello de la camisa.
Y le acerco, y resulta que es más alto que yo pero la capa ayuda,
por lo que me escucha cuando le miro directamente a los ojos.
Y le digo solo esto: "Vete a casa".
Y lo hace, mirando por encima del hombro a cada paso,
mientras yo salto de edificio en edificio adelantándome
porque sé dónde vive.
Y veo como le tiemblan las manos mientras saca la llave
y abre la puerta de su edificio.
Y estoy de vuelta en mi cama
mucho antes de que él entre por la puerta principal.
Y lo escucho abrir el grifo, servirse un vaso de agua caliente del grifo
poner el vaso de vuelta en el fregadero.
Y escucho sus pasos.
Y el ruido disminuye mientras se acerca a mi habitación.
Y entreabre la puerta muy, muy lentamente.
Y entra, lo que nunca hizo hasta ahora.
(Golpe)
Y está mirando el vacío, con un rostro del mismo color que las aceras en verano.
Y finjo que acabo de despertarme
y digo, "¿Qué pasa, papá?"
Y el conserje no me dice nada.
Pero yo veo en la oscuridad.
Veo como sus brazos se relajan, su cabeza gira hacía mí
y la levanta para que pueda ver su cara y sus ojos.
Y sus mejillas están mojadas pero no de sudor,
mientras se queda ahí con la respiración entrecortada
como si recordara mis ojos brillando y mi pecho a prueba de balas,
como si recordara que es mi papá.
Y me quedo sin decir nada.
Él se da la vuelta con la mano en el picaporte.
Ya no me mira.
Pero oigo como murmulla:
"Lo siento".
Y vuelvo a echarme en la cama y abro la ventana solo un poco.
Si miras lo suficientemente alto,
puedes verme.
Y desde dónde estoy...
(Platillos)
Puedo oírlo todo.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.